hallo leute ist wieder eure wahl manne
hallo leute ich es wieder eure mal waren
und willkommen zu einem neuen video
willkommen how die partner ich habe in
den letzten tagen sehr viele disney
filme geschaut was vielleicht daran
liegen könnte dass ein gewisser
streaming-dienst gelaunched ist ich will
jetzt hier mal keinen namen
disney plus und deswegen habe ich lust
bekommen disney prinzessinnen zu malen
beziehungsweise mich als eine disney
prinzessin zu malen und dann habe ich
das vorhin gemacht ich hab mich in
bahrain gemalt hammer oder ich weiß
mittlerweile ist das frauenbild was sie
vermitteln nicht mehr ganz so aktuell
trotzdem bin ich mit diesen
prinzessinnen aufgewachsen und ich fand
sie immer toll und wunderschön und sie
konnten alle schön sehen konnten mit
tieren reden oder arm sehr viel zeit mit
tieren verbracht waren auf jeden fall
immer nett zu tieren das ist ein gutes
vorbild ich sage mal so ich wollte schon
immer eine prinzessin sein und heute ist
der perfekte tag dafür aber schauen wir
uns doch mal an was ich denn jetzt schon
gemalt habe wow ich bin euch mal das
video ab es gibt ja so ein cooles
zeitraum mio
ich habe mich zuerst für bell
entschieden weil ich dachte wegen der
haarfarbe und der augenfarbe und weil
sie ein gelbes kleidern hat passt es
eigentlich perfekt ich glaube aber dass
ich auch noch zu den anderen disney
prinzessin werden kann
und ich hab dir gesehen ich ein bisschen
was mit hautfarbe ausprobiert da noch
meine ein comic brille hinzugefügt die
haare gemacht und das war es dann auch
so wurde ich zu bett können wir mal
darüber sprechen dass bell eigentlich
den ganzen film über so ein schlichtes
kleid anhat aber wenn man bell googelt
man kriegt nur die bell im gelben kleid
jetzt stellt sich allerdings die frage
zu welcher disney prinzessin werde ich
als nächstes mit disney prinzessin zu
was kommt dann
das ist eine große sammlung
schneewittchen cinderella aschenputtel
ariel die nächste disney prinzessin zu
der ich werden möchte ist ariel perfekt
dieses wurde er nicht so jetzt haben wir
unsere ariel hier vom volumen würde ich
sagen habe ich schon ariel artige haare
weil man sagen wo es ariel hat wirklich
also diese haare gehen bis über den
arsch doch so lange haare habe ich nicht
die disney prinzessinnen von früher
hatten natürlich nicht so viel make-up
drauf wobei man sagen muss die lashes
sind wirklich und fliegt aber wer mich
kennt weiß dass ich meine fake lashes
brauche die da reicht mir das nicht wir
sind kajalstift brauchen wir unten auch
und natürlich hier auch die wimpern okay
die augenfarbe stimmt nicht meine augen
sind viel wie dunkler meine haben auch
schon sehr dunklen rand
das heißt ich geb dir mir ein stein und
schon hat sie braune augen
ok ich trage deutlich mehr make-up als
ariel welche farbe aus unserer
lidschatten palette werden wir heute
nehme ich glaube ich tendiere zu dem
hellen pink oder zudem pink wir
probieren man das aus ist zwar nicht die
jeffrey star eyeshadow pellet aber kommt
schon klar
okay leute ganz wichtig ihr müsst euren
lidschatten verblenden so beautiful und
mehr ist immer mehr sag ich war hammer
als nächstes sind die augenbrauen dran
denn diese augenbrauen die kommen aus
den 50er jahren kam ariel in den 50er
oder raus ja gut ariel kam 1989 raus das
sind fast die fünfziger aber in den
90ern haben sie auch in den 90ern hatten
sie auch sehr dünnen augenbrauen
deswegen haben sie sich wahrscheinlich
daran orientiert also um unsere
augenbrauen gens hilft es hier dicke
augenbrauen also so dicke jetzt auch
nicht auf jeden fall mehr als das und
sie dürfen ja auch heutzutage dürfen wir
sie ein bisschen und perfekter tragen
ich habe endlich
[Musik]
kelly bringt million jetzt kommen wir
natürlich zum lippenstift und ich trag
nicht so gerne roten lippenstift das
heißt wir nehmen einen etwas
natürlicheren tonart ist herr magath ist
schön
also ich würde schon sagen ich gottes zu
leuten mit großen lippen ein bisschen
größer
ja doch ihr glück nie meine zähne sind
nicht so weiß ich würde schon sagen ich
gebe mehr in ihre gelb richtung der
fairness halber habe ich mir ein
bisschen gelbe zähne gemacht ok kommen
wir zum schwierigsten part und zwar die
haare da gibt es ungefähr ariels kopf
lang ich mag eigentlich schon hier diese
ganze welle natürlich weniger aber mein
pony ist ja ein pony geht ja hier so und
dann gehen meine haare von hier los aber
keiner hat das hier mit hat doch niemand
real hat ja auch so sehr voluminös h
damit gehe ich ja noch der chor und hier
ist aber auch mal gut so ganz will ich
noch das pony ja das sind dann um für
meine haare
ich muss einfach gerade ariel songs
hören tätig ihr dürft das nicht hören
denn es ist copyright musik und das
video wird and monetarisiert und dann ja
das ist schrecklich
komm komm ich kein geld
[Musik]
ja das ist mein braun
harvard haben schnauzbart oh mein gott
ich muss jetzt nur definitiv die stirn
in ordnung kriegen wir den berg
vergessen
jetzt wiege ich kein dorf was jetzt ein
bisschen schwierig sein wird es diese
schattierung in den haaren richtig
hinzubekommen meine sehne am rest zum
bild noch sehr platt aus dann machen wir
aus unserer ebene eine affäre
so können wir nicht über malen seht ihr
wenn ich jetzt mit dem pinsel lang
gemalt ist nur das an was die haare sind
und dann brauchen wir unseren airbrush
pinsel
[Musik]
für dich gut sorry areal deine haare
müssen jetzt endgültig gehen also leute
das lässt sich doch sehen ein accessoire
fehlt noch und das ist meine brille die
ich eigentlich immer an hat und dann bin
ich eine richtige meerjungfrau
[Musik]
ja es nie leute it's me bitten radio ich
erkenne den unterschied
wie wäre es denn wenn ich diese tattoos
hat für eine vollkatastrophe werden
meine tattoos was habe ich denn hier
ich habe hier einmal pocahontas
[Musik]
oh mein gott dann sieht man noch eine
blume der welt einen geburtstagskuchen
tut muss reichen leute und das bin ich
als ariel
ganz ehrlich ich bin super gemacht so
ich finde ariel ist mir schon mal
gelungen machen wir weiter mit der
nächsten zu welcher disney prinzessin
werde ich als nächstes wie ihr wisst bin
ich ein großer pocahontas fan und
deswegen wird unsere dritte prinzessin
pocahontas wir fangen natürlich wieder
mit den augen an und da fällt mir gleich
auf das pocahontas noch mehr eilig es
braucht denn wir lieben es ist ja wohl
die augenfarbe ist schon fast richtig
ich würde aber sagen dass ich noch ein
bisschen dunklere augen haben wir hier
wieder das klassische pinke make up
[Musik]
die augenbrauen auch definitiv ein
makeover das gefühl disney wollte keine
buschigen augenbrauen für seine
prinzessinnen aber das ändern wir heute
augenbrauen müssen nicht so perfekt sein
werk schon perfekte augenbraue von
pocahontas ist so winzig ihre nase ist
einfach so ein strich keine ahnung ich
brauche auf jeden fall noch größere
nasenflügel ihre lippen sehen jetzt
wieder ganz anders aus als meine nehme
ich lieber mein vater hier wie
was ich mir hier so ein bisschen mehr
wünsche ist highlighter ja seht ihr
wovon die rede
richtiges instagram model plötzlich
geworden und mein gott was habe ich mit
dem kind gemacht so es besser ja meine
haarfarbe kann da mithalten
warum hat sie eigentlich schwarze haare
die blau leuchten
kennt ihr dieses draht spieler von
früher das fühlt sich genauso an yes
that's my pony so jetzt brauchen wir wie
der alfa wäre dann airbrush dann nehmen
wir eine rutsche dunkle farbe dann
gucken wir dass unser erschien nicht
gleich ausrastet jetzt müssen wir das
wieder 3d machen leute nicht verzagen da
muss einfach wieder eine goldene brille
drauf wenn wir innehalten wieder eine
goldene brille drauf packen dann wird
das wieder hier richtig gut aussehen her
das einzige problem an sich haben ist
die hautfarbene ich versuche einfach mal
ein airbrush rüber zu gehen
[Musik]
so ist irgendwie strange jetzt mit der
hautfarbe aber gut besucht so auszusehen
exklusive also bitte das sieht ja wohl
fantastisch aus halo ersten jesu florist
genau so sehe ich aus
das ist mal final look also ich muss
sagen die ariel gefällt mir glaube ich
am besten aber man sieht für die
entwicklung oder ich finde man kann vor
die entwicklung sehen das war mein
erstes bild das war dann das zweite also
pocahontas und ariel sie mehr sind wir
wirklich gut gelungen ich glaube areal
ist mir am besten gelungen welche disney
prinzessin hat euch am meisten gefallen
pocahontas oder ariel schreibt gerne in
die kommentare und falls sie einem
zweiten teil sehen wollt dann neigt und
schreibt auch in die kommentare mir ist
auf jeden fall aufgefallen dass ich viel
öfter am ipad malen muss denn man kommt
erst so richtig in übung wenn man es
öfter macht wie bei allen dingen im
leben so ist das halt wenn du etwas
können willst dann musst du gut üben
üben und dann wirst du zu ariel
ich hoffe euch hat das zuschauen spaß
gemacht und wenn dem so ist dann gibt
mir die an einen daumen nach oben
wir sehen uns beim nächsten video wieder
ich hoffe euch geht's gut bleibt gesund
bleibt zu hause und bis bald tun falls
sie wissen wollt wie lange ich für eine
person gebraucht habe eine stunde eine
stunde pro bild das ist doch mal eine
hausnummer
ich bin jetzt auch müde